everybody that i had on the show at the
end of the show would say something to
me like
um
is that okay you will find true success
and happiness
if you have only one goal there really
is only one and that is this
to fulfill
the highest
most truthful
expression
of yourself
for me colored girl negro child
growing up in mississippi
that one of the greatest gifts i was
ever afforded was not to have been put
in a segregated school system
empowerment is authority
it is a sign permission slip to actually
seize the day every failure every crisis
every difficult time i say what is this
here to teach me any life and every life
is enhanced by the sharing and the
giving and the opening up of the heart
space your life gets better when you can
find a way to share it with someone else
people can't figure out how i got to be
so successful it is because i have lived
in the space of spirit my whole life i
had a job until i could figure out what
it was really
what that gave my life its purpose and
meaning but having a lot of money does
not automatically
make you a successful person
what you want
is money
and meaning
i know a lot of rich people who are not
happy
but i am not one of them
but when you're i am one of the happiest
rich people you are ever going to see
need motivation
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best oprah winfrey
and my take on her top 10 rules of
success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one pay attention and learn i'm
going to continue developing shows that
speak
to
the humanity of people in a way that
makes them want to
live better and do better
and
that exalts their
their their victories and lets them know
that they are important and meaningful
in the world you know i would have to
say
that
every day david that show was such a it
was like therapy for me kind of like now
every day this show
was
i paid attention so i've never been to a
therapist but i i i paid attention all
those days on the show and i made
therapy acceptable for a lot of people
who thought ah not me not so
one of the things i started to get
uh
around
mid to late no no mid to late 90s is
that everybody that i had on the show at
the end of the show would say something
to me like
um
was that okay was that okay how was that
was that okay right at the end of the
interview
and i started to then track it it didn't
matter if it was um i i i had gone and
done a show where i was in um
a prison i was interviewing a father
who
was in jail for life for murdering his
twin daughters and at the end of the
interview even behind bars he said to me
is that okay
how'd i do
and barack obama said it when he sat in
the chair the first time and george bush
said it beyonce said it at the end of
she taught me how to talk and then said
is that okay
so that's an acquired skill do you think
yes
working thing but this is what i learned
uh sitting in that chair for 25 years
that at the end of the day
whether you are
interviewing me or i get to interview
you
whatever your profession is
wherever you are in your life in your
relationships
every person that you encounter every
experience the person wants to know
was that okay
was that okay
and what i started to hear was that what
people are really saying is did you hear
me
did you hear me
and did what i say mean anything to you
and so i started to listen
with that in mind with that intention of
validating that your being here
you're speaking to me you're taking the
time to do this with me is important
because you matter and that's true for
everybody who's watching or listening
that every argument that you ever have
every encounter the person just wants to
know did you hear me did you see me and
did i say anything
rule number two max out your humanity
you will find true success and happiness
if you have only one goal there really
is only one and that is this
to fulfill
the highest
most truthful
expression of yourself
as a human being
you want to max out your humanity
by using your energy to lift yourself up
your family and the people around you
theologian howard thurman said it best
he said don't ask yourself what the
world needs
ask yourself what makes you come alive
and then go do that
because what the world needs is people
who have come alive
the world needs
[Music]
people like michael stalzenberg from
fort lauderdale when michael was just
eight years old michael nearly died from
a bacterial infection that cost him both
of his hands and both of his feet and in
an instant this vibrant little boy
became a quadruple amputee
and his life
was changed forever
but in losing who he once was
michael discovered who he wanted to be
he refused to sit in that wheelchair all
day and feel sorry for himself so with
prosthetics he learned to walk
and run and play again
he joined his middle school lacrosse
team
and last month when he learned that so
many victims of the boston marathon
bombing would become new amputees
michael decided to banish that darkness
with light
michael and his brother harris created
mikeysrun.com
to raise one million dollars for other
amputees
by the time harris runs the 2014 boston
marathon
more than a thousand miles away from
here
these two young brothers
are bringing people together to support
this boston community the way their
community came together to support
michael and when this 13 year old man
was asked about his fellow amputees he
said this
first
they will be sad
they're losing something
they will never get back
and that's scary
i was scared
but they'll be okay
they just don't know that yet
we might not always know it
we might not always see it or hear it on
the news or even feel it in our daily
lives but i have faith
that no matter what
class of 2013
you will be okay
and you will make sure our country is
okay
i have faith because of that
nine-year-old girl who went out and
collected the change
i have faith because of david and
francine wheeler i have faith because of
michael and harris stolzenberg and i
have faith because of you the network of
angels sitting here today one of them
khadijah williams
who came to harvard four years ago
khadijah had attended 12 schools in 12
years
living out of garbage bags
amongst pimps and prostitutes and drug
dealers
homeless
going into department stores walmart in
the morning to bathe herself so that she
wouldn't smell in front of her
classmates
and today she graduates as a member of
the harvard class
of 2013. rule number three believe
you're worthy for me colored girl negro
child
growing up in mississippi
that one of the greatest gifts i was
ever afforded was not to have been put
in a segregated school system
had i been put in a segregated school
and taught in a segregated school system
that said you're less than because
you're a woman and you're less than
because you're a colored woman
i probably wouldn't be here today i
would have had to then overcome that
belief that conditioning of a belief but
because
i was raised by a grandmother
who
raised me in the church
and
i went to church
sunday school
[Music]
lived in the church and i would sit
there
second pew
on the right
third row
every sunday
just
taking it all in and i would listen to
the stories listen to the bible stories
and i would hear
that through god all things are possible
i would hear the story of jesus talking
about
if you have the faith of a mustard seed
and you know it was many years later
that i actually
saw a mustard seed i could not believe
what a mustard seed actually looked like
have you ever seen a mustard seed here i
have some here
i want to pull one out now jesus said if
you had the faith of a mustard seed you
could move mountains
and anything was possible now i heard
this as a kid and i really believed it
and so the question is what do you
believe
do you believe that you are worthy of
happiness do you believe that happiness
success
abundance
comfort fulfillment peace joy
love
is a part of your birthright
is that what you believe
or do you believe something else because
you will
manifest
the life that you believe
i've always known that no matter what my
belief is i'm going to be all right why
because i have that faith of a mustard
seed rule number four take charge
empowerment is authority
it is a sign permission slip to actually
seize the day
it's the process of getting stronger and
more confident and more engaged and to
be empowered is to move to the world
without any kind of fear or any kind of
apology and with these gifts comes an
even deeper privilege i believe and that
is the ability to take charge of your
own life to own yourself and claim your
rights and here's what i know for sure
that to whom much is given much is
expected
and i have been given so much
i've earned it
i've been blessed with it
but i've been given a lot
and that's why i've chosen to use my
life to lift other people up
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief i've
designed a special free training to help
you do it the sign says it can take up
to 254 days of consecutive action to
build a new habit and i want that for
you i want you to build the habit of
self belief so what i'm going to do is
email you every day for 254 days a link
to an unlisted video that will shift
your belief forward to get on it for
free the link to join is in the
description below
figure out
where your power base is
your number one job is to become more of
yourself
and to grow yourself into the best of
yourself become so skilled
so vigilant so flat out fantastic
at what you do that your talent cannot
be dismissed rule number five learn from
the challenges nobody's journey is
seamless or smooth we all stumble we all
have setbacks if things go wrong you hit
a dead end as you will
it's just life's way of saying
time to change course
so ask every failure this is what i do
every failure every crisis every
difficult time i say what is this here
to teach me
and as soon as you get the lesson you
get to move on if you really get the
lesson you pass and you don't have to
repeat the class if you don't get the
lesson it shows up wearing another pair
of pants
or skirt
to give you some remedial work
and what i found is that difficulties
come when you don't pay attention to
life's whisper
because life always whispers to you
first first and if you ignore the
whisper sooner or later you'll get a
scream
whatever you resist persists but if you
ask the right question not why is this
happening but what is this here to teach
me what is this here to teach me it puts
you in the place and space to get the
lesson you need my friend ed cartoli
who's written this wonderful book
uh called a new earth
that's all about letting the awareness
of who you are stimulate everything that
you do he puts it like this he says
don't react against a bad situation
merge with that situation instead and
the solution will arise from the
challenge
because surrendering yourself doesn't
mean giving up it means acting with
responsibility
okay
many of you know that as president
hennessey said i started this school
in africa
and
i founded the school where i'm trying to
give south african girls a shot at a
future like yours stanford
and i spent five years making sure that
school would be as beautiful as the
students
i wanted every girl to feel her worth
reflected in her surroundings so i
checked every blueprint
i picked every pillow
i was looking at the grout in between
the bricks i knew every thread count of
the sheets i chose every girl from the
villages from nine provinces and yet
last fall i was faced with a crisis i'd
never anticipated i was told that one of
the dorm matrons was suspected of sexual
abuse
well that was as you can imagine
devastating news
first i cried actually i sobbed for
about a half an hour
and then i said let's get to it that's
all you get is a half an hour you need
to focus on the now
what you need to do now so i contacted a
child trauma specialist i put together a
team of investigators i made sure the
girls had counseling and support and
gail and i got on a plane and flew to
south africa and the whole time i kept
asking that question
what is this here to teach me
and as difficult as that experience has
been i got a lot of lessons
i understand now the mistakes i made
because i had been paying attention to
all of the wrong things
i built that school from the outside in
when what really mattered was the inside
out
so it's a lesson that applies to all of
our lives as a whole what matters most
is what's inside what matters most is
the sense of
integrity of quality and beauty i got
that lesson and what i know is is that
the girls came away with something too
they've emerged from this more resilient
and knowing that their voices
have power rule number six serve i have
always known this about celebrity
the real
power of being
somebody that somebody knows and i
really think that the only difference
between being famous and not is that
more people know your name
so the only difference
between understanding that
is understanding that what selma has
done what susan has done what anna has
done rebecca has done what jim has done
what i've done
you two can do
because true philanthropy comes from
living from the heart of yourself
and giving what you have been given
how will you do that
how will you use
your personality
the energy of your personality
to serve that which is your soul's
calling
i know this for sure
any life
no matter how fantastic it is
how glorious it seems how much attention
you receive
how much square footage you have
any life and every life is enhanced by
the sharing and the giving and the
opening up of the heart space
your life gets better when you can find
a way to share it with someone else
so what we've done you can do the real
empowerment comes when every person
leaves this room
and makes a decision
makes a
decision maybe that decision is that you
will write a check and support some of
the wonderful organizations you've heard
here today
but the true decision is
how will you use yourself
how will you use everything that you
have been given
to serve that which is greater than
yourself
how will you use that to become
truly
authentically empowered
now
it is a beautiful thing to receive an
award and to be on the cover of variety
thank you very much
it's a beautiful thing
but the true reward is in the lives that
you are able to touch and the people who
you know you have impacted rule number
seven tap into your spirituality are you
ready to allow abundance and blessings
people can't figure out how i got to be
so successful it is because i have lived
in the space of spirit my whole life
my favorite bible verse because i am
christian uh is
acts
something
i used to note a number but this was an
axe y'all can google it
but it says
thank you 1728
in god i live and move and have my being
i live and move and have my being and
you want to know why i am really so
successful
i knew that at four years old
i knew that when my grandmother said you
better watch me now because one day you
have to learn how to wash these clothes
and hang them up like this so watch how
i hold these clothes pins in my mouth
[Applause]
and the reason i could do that is
because spirit
otherwise known as intuition
my instinct said
that's not gonna be my life
so we all have that spiritual side and
this lesson tonight is about connecting
to it i believe that beneath the surface
of all physical problems is a spiritual
solution
there is a spiritual solution why
because you are a spiritual being
having a human experience that's the
beginning of understanding spirituality
you are a spiritual being
having a human
experience rule number eight find your
passion i had a job until i could figure
out what it was really
what that gave my life its purpose and
meaning
and
i'd gotten demoted in my job in
baltimore as an anchor woman because
as they hired me and then they decided i
was the wrong color
and i was the wrong size and i was the
wrong you know i had lots of problems
and they were trying to take me off the
air
and um
i was making 22 000 a year i thought i
was in heaven because i was making my
age and my dream at the time was gail
and i used to say can you imagine if
you're 40 and you're making 40 000 would
that be it
so um
uh that was as big as my dream was just
to make my age
and then i did this they they put me on
a talk show one morning because um
they didn't know what to do with me
and and i was interviewing the carvel
ice cream man it was a local talk show
and
um
benny from um
benny who was mrs
chancellors
uh butler or something on all my
children anyway my soap opera star who
wasn't the lead star remember benny
benny and the caravel ice cream man
that's how i cut my teeth and i finished
that show so it's not about the the
the stars themselves or whoever the
guests were but i felt like this is what
i'm supposed to do all these years have
been misplaced in news because i
couldn't relate to news i was a news
reporter and i'd be out on the stories
and i'd be crying with the people
and i felt that i was exploiting the
people with news i couldn't
you know put a microphone in people's
face when they were going through
tragedies and stuff i just was so
emotional i was always getting little
notes from my boss about cut that out
you need to stop so but the moment i did
that talk show i felt like oh
i can be myself
and that was august 14 1978
and that was the beginning of fulfilling
the calling and so since that time
since that time august 14th 1978 i've
never had a problem with energy now when
i was working in news i used to be
exhausted all the time because i just
exhausted all the time because i hated
it
and the reason i didn't quit is because
i'm not a quitter number one and cause
my father was like better not quit that
job you're making twenty two thousand
dollars a year
who's gonna play a black woman between
two thousand dollars a year you're never
gonna make make that kind of money again
you better save half of it so
i i was reluctant to quit and think
about doing something else because i
thought okay
everybody wants to be an anchor woman at
the time that was like supposedly a big
deal being an anchor woman so i thought
okay i won't i'll just stay with this
until i can figure out what is the best
thing to do and interestingly enough i
was applying for what i wanted to do
i felt like i needed to be able to talk
and at the time the only thing that was
available was um
was uh like good morning america or
today show so i called up this agent and
i asked if he would accept my tape
because i wanted to be like a substitute
for brian gumbel and he said to me
there was only going to be one brian
gumbel and so
there wasn't going to be another one
that they weren't going to let another
black person on that show he said that
to me
and um interestingly enough he called me
last week because somebody else mentions
it to say he never said it but he did
say it and i said to him you know what
if you're ever told that you never
forget it if somebody ever says to you
if you're ever rejected in that way you
never ever ever forget it i said but
it's okay i did okay you did okay
it's all right but the answer to your
question is if you can find what is your
passion if you find what you love you
never get tired or if you do get tired
you you're fueled by the energy of your
work so i know that i'm doing exactly
what i'm supposed to be doing at this
time
i also know that what the the show can
do
in terms of being
a voice and changing the world it's just
the beginning of what this show can do
it's fun to do things like this
but uh and it's necessary to do things
like this in order to be able to do the
bigger grander things to change what
happens to to the face of children in
africa for example what happens to
education with kids in in this country
so i believe that um
that what has happened to me is really
the beginning
of the greater passion to come
but if you find out what you're supposed
to do and you know what you're supposed
to do by how it feels
you know people wait on the voice of god
to be some the moses in burning bush i
think that was only bible talk
you know because he doesn't come to
burning bushes for people he comes
through your heart
he speaks through your heart through
your feelings and so you know what if
you're doing the right thing if it feels
like it's right to you and when you hit
the thing that feels right when you know
it's the right thing you would you know
it's right because it gives you your
juice
and you know it's right because you
would do it for nothing
you would do it for nothing and find a
way to be able just to do it
in order to be able to continue
that's how you know you're doing what
you're supposed to be doing rule number
nine find meaning how do i define
success
let me tell you money's pretty nice
i'm not going to stand up here and tell
you that it's not about money because
money is very nice
i like money
it's good for buying things
[Applause]
but having a lot of money does not
automatically
make you a successful person
what you want
is money
and meaning
you want your work to be meaningful
because meaning is what brings the real
richness to your life
what you really want
is to be surrounded by people you trust
and treasure and by people who cherish
you
that's when you're really rich and rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is be happy i'm
content i'm not just relaxed i'm content
because i know a lot of rich people who
are not happy
but i am not one of them
but when you're recruiting i am one of
the happiest rich people you are ever
going to see
when you're trying to just
when you're trying to get away from it
all and just get away from everything
you just relax at one of your homes or
yes i realize well and also it doesn't
take a lot for me to relax i can uh i
can be happy looking at a leaf yeah gail
is saying what are you sitting out under
the trees with your thoughts and i'll
say yeah i'm really i could be happy
with the book i can be happy reading
poetry i can be happy in front of a fire
i can be happy with my dogs i can be
yeah all right
thank you now i've got a special bonus
clip that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week when you just get inspired
you watch a video you get motivated
amazing the science says you have a 35
chance of actually doing something
actually following through that believe
nation is not enough that is not you not
now not anymore not today but when you
get inspired and then you create a
specific plan of action for what you're
going to do that number jumps to 91
chance of you following through and when
you commit publicly to others like
leaving a comment in this video it jumps
to 95
so the question of the day is your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and maybe next week i'll profile you
from time to time you may stumble
fall you will for sure count on this
no doubt
you will have questions
and you will have doubts about your path
but i know this if you're willing to
listen
to be guided by that still small voice
that is the gps within yourself
to find out what makes you come alive
you will be more than okay
you will be
happy
you will be successful
and you will make a difference in the
world you know my salary
or my earnings
were
published all over the place i mean the
first year i was like really did i make
that much money oh my god
um
it was very difficult for me to figure
out where my boundaries were
because i'd grown up poor and didn't
have anything
so it's easy when you don't have
anything and people ask you for money
and they say i need 500 i don't have it
because i'm just trying to get my rent
paid
it's harder when your
multi-billion dollar salary is now in
the paper and you get a lot of friends
and cousins you didn't have before
so how do you set
boundaries for yourself i was having
trouble setting boundaries myself for
myself for even strangers people would
just show up at my door in chicago and
say oh bro i left my husband please help
me
and i would because
she knows i have it
so
don't try that now though okay
don't try that now i figured it out
so what i learned was is that
oh the reason why people keep showing up
is because my intention is to make them
think that i'm such a nice person
that
you can ask me for anything
you can get me to do anything i'm going
to say yes i'm going to say yes so when
stevie called me this time i thought i'd
try out my first no on stevie let's
start big
he wanted me to donate some money to a
charity and i didn't want to donate to
the charity
because
i have my own charities and i care about
a lot of people but the the problem is
when you you have money everybody thinks
you just want to give to everything so
every letter i ever get starts with we
know you love the children
yes i do love the children but somebody
else is gonna have to help the children
so i said to stevie uh i said to stevie
no
and um
as a person who has that disease to
please i was waiting for him then just
to say
i will never speak to you again
i will never call you i will never sing
a song for you
and he didn't he just said okay
[Music]
okay
okay it's okay he said okay check you
later
and
what i learned from that is
many times you will have angst and worry
about things and
put yourself in a state like someone
said this morning because their phone
went off they were mortified over a
phone i said really
you will put yourself in a state when
the other person really isn't even
thinking about you so
learning that i could specifically
determine for myself what the boundaries
were for me
what i wanted to do
give my money give my time give of my
service to who i wanted to give it to
when i did that i get to make that
decision and just because you get 100
requests a week doesn't mean you have to
try to fulfill all of that just because
you have all of these demands on your
time and on you doesn't mean that you
have to say yes you get to decide
because you're the master of your fate
the captain of your soul as william
ernest henley said in invictus
and understanding that
really changed the meaning of my life in
that i was not
no longer driven by what
other people wanted me to do
but took charge of my own destiny making
choices based upon what do i feel
is the next right move for me
you must find a way to serve
martin luther king
said that not everybody can be famous
but everybody can be great because
greatness is determined
by service
now we live in a world where everybody
wants to be famous
and where we admire people for just
being famous
we think being known brings us value
the truth is all of that will fade
in time
in three years you won't be able to name
the housewives of atlanta
[Music]
the real truth
is that
service and significance
service and the significance that you
bring to your service
is that which is lasting
so to be able to whatever your
occupation or job or talent or gift is
our honorees today
getting doctor degrees
to
apparently opposite fields hiv and aids
and the spoken word
but what they have in common
is service
using the spoken word in service to
community and the world
using your knowledge and information
about hiv and aids and medicine in
service to the world and if you look at
all the most successful people in the
world
whether they know it or not
they have that paradigm of service
everybody's talking about mark
zuckerberg and ipo
[Music]
service
[Music]
jay-z rapid
service
through the word
to people through song
for many years i was really just happy
to be on tv and people would stop and
say oh you on tv yeah i'm on tv
i like being on tv
it's a nice job
and it was about the time that i
received my
honorary doctorate from spelman around
1993 so i don't know if that had
something to do with it i thought of
myself as dr winfrey
[Music]
that i went back and i took a long look
at what it was i was doing on
on tv
and made a decision
that i was no longer going to just be on
tv
but i was going to use tv
as a platform
as a force for good
and not be used by tv
and i will tell you
[Music]
my decision
to make that significant change in the
way i operated
on television using television as a
service
changed my career exponentially
service
through
medicine service through
art
using whatever it is you produce your
product
as a way of giving back to the world
when you shift the paradigm of whatever
it is you choose to do to service and
you bring significance to that
success will i promise you follow you
service
and significance
equals success on one of the shows it
was so impressive for me to see all the
shows that we've done lord made me tired
looking at it uh
but i was interviewing a woman
it was a show called
the
mistress
the wives meet the mistresses or some
crazy thing and this woman was on and
it was a live show and in the middle of
it her husband tells
the wife and our entire audience and the
world that his mistress was pregnant
yes
to this day makes my eyes water because
i saw
his wife's face
and i felt her humiliation
and i said i will quit tv if i have to
do this i won't do this anymore
and my producers like what are we going
to do
this is what everybody's doing and then
that same
during that same time period so i said
i'm not going to do anything like that
anymore i'm not going to
not going to bring people on tv and
first of all we didn't know that moment
was going to happen they were like we
didn't know what was going to happen but
that should not happen on television
and i do not want to be a part of the
energy that caused somebody to feel that
because that's not going to come back to
me
i got to pay for that
then i was interviewing the kkk
on stage that was the day the one guy
called me a monkey in the audience and
during commercial break i could see them
signaling each other
and just watching them and their
behavior
i thought oh they get it
i don't get it they are using me
they are using this platform because
they understand because i'm thinking oh
i'm going to tell you all about the kkk
they were using it to recruit members
for themselves they were using it to
recruit their base
and
i then went to the brutalization not
doing a show like that so they said
you're not going to do the mistresses
you know
you're not going to do okay what are we
going to do
so i said we we are going to
um
create a baseline for ourselves that's
based on intention this was around 1989
when i'd read gary zhukov's book called
the seat of the soul
and that book was life-changing for me
because in it he talked about the power
of intention
and that
cause and effect
what goes out comes back
is determined
by your intention the energy of your
intention
is what determines your life
most people don't think about their
intention they just think about what
they want to do
most people don't think about why they
want to do it
but what's going to come back to you the
energy that's going to come back to you
is the real why of why you did it
and so i then said to my producers we're
not going to do any shows that are not
intentional so don't bring me an idea
unless you have an intention for the
show that you want the outcome to be and
we're going to strive to see if we can
live up to our intentions and so around
the late 80s we started a pre-show to
talk about what the intention was and
then a post-show after every single show
to say did we fulfill that intention and
that's about the time i realized this is
bigger than me after i left the oprah
show i made a conscious decision
that i did not want to be sitting on tv
with the oprah show and y'all saying she
should have left that show
that show was really good two years ago
i made a conscious decision decision
that when i felt i had said
all that i could say
and the audience had heard it
that i would move on and that i would
not spend my life regretting or trying
to hold on to what used to be or hold on
to what i had so i dreamed this dream
of starting a network
and in the beginning it was it was a
struggle
it was a struggle because
i didn't
honestly goodness i did not know what i
was doing
i was trying to figure it out
i was trying to figure it out i thought
that the oprah show audience would
follow us to own and then i realized
y'all didn't have cable
and if you had cable you did not have
the own package
[Music]
[Applause]
so
so it took me a minute
and unlike most people who you get to
have your mistakes in private some don't
go right in your life you get to sulk
about it in private if i make a mistake
it's on the cnn crawl
or the cnn news so when i was in the
climb and there were so many wonderful
owners i see churro action jackson here
there were so many wonderful owners
people who said oh we're gonna stand
with you we're gonna stand by you thank
you roland martin there were so many
people who said listen we believe that
this can happen
so i dreamed the dream
along with tyler perry who was my friend
who came to me and said tyler
tyler said i'm going to help you out
because tyler can go home and write a
script and direct it produce it and
shoot it
and do it for less money than anybody in
hollywood so we started with the
foundation of having have not
if loving you is wrong
love thy neighbor
mama hattie
and then i started to dream another
dream about
scripted television because in the
beginning i was told you couldn't do it
you couldn't do it didn't have enough
money to do it
and
i dreamed the dream
i read proverbs 11 28 that says those
who trust in their riches will fall but
the righteous will rise and thrive like
a green leaf actually i did this at the
end of my uh
uh show i did my favorite guest of all
times that's hard to do out of
literally
thousands and thousands they they
supposedly estimated that there's like
35 000 people i interviewed over the
years but
there was one woman out of all the
celebrities out of all of the
famous non-famous infamous people one
woman
who was she her name is tarai trent
listen to the story
i'm going to try to shorten it for you
okay terror right trent born and raised
in a village in zimbabwe 11 years old
she's doing her brother's homework she
wants to go to school her father says no
you're a girl you have to educate the
boy yes that's right
that's right the boy has to go to school
you can't go to school so she starts
doing her brother's homework
she does his brother's homework he goes
to school he gets all a's on his
homework yet he doesn't know the answer
to the question the teacher comes to the
village to say what is going on here
this boy doesn't know the answers but
his homework's perfect she finds out
that tererai his younger sister is doing
his homework she begs the father to let
tararai go to school the father says no
she can't go to school finally he
marries her off she marries at 11 and a
half years old she gets married she has
three children by the time she's 18
years old a woman comes to the village
from an ngo heifer international and
asks what are your dreams this is going
to make me cry finally
what are your dreams
this child has never thought about what
her dreams were she says write down your
dreams she writes down her dreams on a
piece of paper and she folds them in a
tin can and she buries them under a rock
the first dream was to be able to go to
the school and go to a school in the
united states of america
and get a college degree
she ends up
through some miracle of the ngo going to
the united states she gets a college
degree wow yes she gets a four-year
degree in three years terrorized trent
she goes back to the rock in zimbabwe
she writes her next goal on the piece of
paper she buries it under the rock she
writes i want to get a master's degree
she goes back to uni and said she gets a
master's degree by this time she now has
five children she's married to a man who
still beats her
incredible
she goes back until she gets her
master's degree after the master's
degree she goes back to the rock in
zimbabwe she writes down her final goal
is to get a doctorate degree and last
year she became dr tararai trent where
did you find it where did i find it um
i found
her
in the in the nicholas kristoff's book
called uh
something the sky underneath the sky or
this guy and nico i found her in
nicholas christoph's book
and i was reading the story
i had nicholas kristoff on the show
nicholas kristoff the famous new york
times writer
and
she wasn't there she wasn't a part of
the ch i'm reading the story i can't
believe this book the story of this
woman as i'm reading the story so when
we go to do the show
the producers have nicholas kristoff on
they bring on other guests but this
woman isn't there i go how could you not
have her there so we tape another show
with nicholas kristoff we go back and go
fine we're going to find that woman
terrorized trent this time by this time
she's living in the united states we
followed her back to zimbabwe to the
rock
we pulled the tin tan from underneath
the rock
and that is my favorite guest of all
time and the worst
um
i don't have a worst i don't have a
worse but the reason why she and as i
said this on my show the reason why tara
wright trent is my favorite guest of all
time is because she represents in that
one story of the little girl in a
village in zimbabwe who had a dream
and the heart and depth and discipline
to pursue it she represents everything i
tried to say in every show in 25 years
she literally through her life story
sums up the message that i was trying to
give to every single one of my viewers
you can
you can
keep trying
don't give up always
do
the right
thing
[Music]
always
[Music]
be
excellent people notice
think of how you notice you go to taco
bell somebody gives you extra napkin and
some sauce
you notice
you want to go back to that person
because even at taco bell
excellence
shows itself
be excellent
let excellence
be your brand
everybody talks about building a brand i
never even knew what that was
when people say your brand i would say
no i'm just oprah
what i recognize now is that my choice
to in every way
in every example in every experience
to do the right thing
and the excellent thing is what has
created the brand
years ago i did an ad for revlon for uh
for an ad
they were doing called unforgettable
women
and what i know is that when you are
excellent
you become
unforgettable
people remember you you stand out
regardless of what it is you become an
unforgettable woman and that is what we
all want we want to be unforgettable and
not forgettable
so doing the right thing even
when nobody knows you're doing the right
thing
will always bring the right thing to you
i promise you that why
because the third law of motion is
always at work for every action there's
an equal and opposite reaction
that is so true in all of our lives
close your eyes for a moment will you
please
and breathe with me just close your eyes
and if you will
put your thumb
to your middle finger
and gather your other fingers around and
let's feel the vibration
and pulse of your personal energy as you
take three deep breaths with me
inhale
and as you exhale just feel
the vibration
energy
blood pulsating
through
your body through you
and another inhale
and another inhale
and keep your eyes closed
and let's just think about
this day
this day that you have been graced
to breathe
in and out
thousands of times
this day
where many of those breaths were taken
for granted you just expected the next
one to come
but the truth is there is no guarantee
that the next one comes
this day
how you started your day what your
thoughts were this morning
how you've carried yourself through this
day
how you've been allowed to have
encounters and experiences
some challenging
some more life enhancing
that push you forward another day
of being here on the planet earth
as a human
being
let's just think about that
after all you've been through
in this day alone
and the many days and years passed
how you got here to this
prestigious esteemed university
the choices you made
that have brought you to this day
open your heart
and quietly to yourself
say the only prayer
that's ever needed
thank you
thank you
thank you
you're still
here and you get another chance
this day
to do better and be better
another chance to become more
of who you were created
and what you were created to fulfill so
for me the foundational base of
empowerment of entrepreneurship of any
kind of engagement the foundational base
of my success
of my well-being my wholeness my
everything is knowing who i am and where
i come from
[Applause]
in my living room right now
is a painting that i've owned now for 30
years
you can google it
it's called to the highest bidder
and it's at the center of my house
and it's at the center of my house
because it actually is symbolic of the
foundation of not the house but the
foundation for my life the painting is
by harry rosalind who was a genre
painter painter in the
early 20th late 19th century
and the painting is over six feet tall
and it shows a slave woman
on the auction block holding her
daughter's hand
and i cannot come in the door my front
door or i cannot leave without passing
that painting i am reminded of where i
come from every day of my life and i am
reminded because i never want to forget
it
and in my library
i have a framed list of enslaved
african-american people remember i
showed you
um who were held in bondage on various
plantations
listed in the ledgers alongside
the cows
and the horses
and the buggies
and the other property
and i passed this list every day
and often i stop in front of it and just
speak their names
out loud and their ages
jonas
11 years old
500 dollars
41 years old
900
elizabeth
57
800
and i forced myself to consider
the absurdity and the obscenity
of prices being affixed to each one
should they be placed up for sale
and i sometimes just pause before them
with a prayer
particularly before i have to make a big
decision about
one of my companies or
whether i move forward or whether i stay
still
it reminds me speaking those names out
loud
not only of where i've come from
but how far
i have to go
because of them
and it reminds me that i am never alone
it reminds me of what i've come through
to get through i think in order to
actually do the stuff yes money is
important but i also think the thing
that i hold the dearest and the reason
why uh
the noise about running for president
moved me so
uh
humbly and deeply is because it means
that you have somewhere in the work
gain the people's trust yes you have and
there is nothing more important to me
than having the trust of the people and
the audience and i i mean i recognize
that it is the audience who came every
day and watched you know from all over
the world that actually yes that that
helped me to be who i am so i think the
uh the the renowned the the the standing
the the ability to be trusted and to say
something but also
listen don't play the billionaire thing
small don't play the be small yeah it's
it's a very big deal because it allows
you to
it allows you to
it allows you to actually do the work so
instead of saying gee i would like to
help so many people or you should go out
and help so many people you can actually
use that for yourself and i am now at
this stage of my career thinking about
how to do that
more poignantly and fruitfully i'm now
looking for ways that i can do that to
create a level of sustainability it
doesn't matter how far you might rise at
some point
you are bound to stumble because if
you're constantly doing what we do
raising the bar
if you're constantly pushing yourself
higher higher
the law of averages not to mention the
myth the vigorous
predicts that you will at some point
fall
and when you do i want you to know this
remember this
there is no such thing as failure
failure is just life trying to move us
in another direction now when you're
down there in a hole it looks like
failure
so this past year i had to spoon feed
those words to myself
and when you're down in the hole when
that moment comes it's really okay to
feel bad for a little while
give yourself time to mourn what you
think you may have lost
but then
here's the key
learn from every mistake
because every
experience encounter and particularly
your mistakes are there to cheat you and
force you into being more of who you are
there's a bigger dream
waiting for you just waiting
for you
to step into it
to step into it your life is big
your life is huge and we spend so much
time
wanting to be in somebody else's life
and you don't get honored
you don't get revered you don't get
celebrating wanting what somebody else
has
[Applause]
because that which created you divine
intelligence that dreamed you from
before your ancestors ever knew
they would become your ancestors that
which dreamed the seed of you
wants you to know how special how
wondrous how mysterious how complex how
glorious how phenomenal you are
and you get no credit
messing in somebody else's territory
or trying to have
power
over something you have no control
another one of my favorite teachings is
the wizard of oz
when the wicked which is the west says
go away from here because you don't have
any power here you have no power in any
territory other than your own
oh
but you are the master of that you get
to be the master of your own fate you
get to be the captain of your own soul
and if you just manage that
if you just took care of your territory
all the glorious glorious glorious
wondrous
wondrous opportunities and possibilities
that are waiting for you so the question
is what are you resisting
what are you pushing against what are
you not allowing what are you blocking
because you have this idea of who and
what you're supposed to be
instead of
leaning into the dream that's already
been created and waiting for you it's
waiting for you and the second i mean it
doesn't it's an instant thing it's a
shift in the way you see yourself and
the power from which you have come you
can't get what you want by focusing on
what you don't want
this is about the need to
establish as many meaningful connections
as we can if we're going to save the
world we have to find a way to connect
to each other
to connect to the nature that we're
killing to animals to history to an
acknowledgement of the lingering trauma
of racism and sexism we need to connect
to the people we love and mean something
to us and more than that to the people
who don't
that doesn't mean we always have to
agree with another person's philosophy
it means
we if we're going to continue to survive
and thrive on this planet have to find
ways to transcend the politics of
division and embrace the places that
bond us where we find our human ground
my television career began unexpectedly
as you heard this morning i was in the
miss fire prevention contest
that was when i was 16 years old in
nashville tennessee
and you had the requirement of having to
have red hair in order to win
up until the year that i entered so they
were doing the question and answer
period because i knew i wasn't going to
win in the swimsuit competition so
during the question and answer period
the question came why young lady what
would you like to be when you grow up
and by the time they got to me all the
good answers were gone
so i had seen barbara walters on the
today show that morning so i answered
i would like to be a journalist
i would like to tell other people's
stories in a way that makes a difference
in their lives and the world
and as those words were coming out of my
mouth i went whoa this is pretty good
i would like to be a journalist i want
to make a difference
well i was on television by the time i
was 19 years old and in 1986 i launched
my own television show with a relentless
determination to succeed at first i was
nervous about the competition and then i
became my own competition
raising the bar every year pushing
pushing pushing myself as hard as i knew
sound familiar to anybody here
eventually we did make it to the top
and we stayed there for 25 years
[Applause]
the oprah winfrey show was number one in
our time slot for 21 years and i have to
tell you i became
pretty comfortable with that level of
success everything you try to do is
already done so when i figured that out
oh what i'm putting out is what's coming
back let me get real clear about what it
is i'm putting out
real clear
so
i read a book about 1989 called seed of
the soul and in that book gary zhukov
talked about
the laws
of karma of
the laws of cause and effect the third
law of motion and in that book he talked
about
how intention your intention
is always
one
with the law
meaning
before you even think about a thing you
have an intention for the thing
and that the intention is going to
determine the outcome
that's why the same people can go to the
same church service
and somebody walked down the aisle just
to be seen to put some money in
the
church
and somebody else who just goes and just
has a little bit to offer
the intention with which you give
the intention with which you serve
determines the outcome so when i figured
that out
i went whoa
i changed everything i did on my show
i called in the producers and i said
from this day forward i will no longer
be speaking to the kkk
i will no longer be speaking to people
who are fighting each other in a way
that it is damaging to the character of
myself and other people who watch
from this day forward i am only going to
do intentional television
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there